I drive for uber to be able to cheat on
my wife with no questions asked about my
whereabouts I'm a lyft driver and last
night I had two passengers pay for me to
go to strip club
best ride ever it's like my lyft drivers
never heard of deodorant
I told him to drop me off three blocks
away because his Bo was so terrible
I had an uber driver who said LGBT
people are messed up and should be
taught a lesson
before I got out the car I told him I
was a lesbian I'm an uber driver and one
of my riders just started rubbing my
shoulders and kissing my neck from
behind my seat didn't leave me her
number
she was hot yay I'm a lyft driver and I
fantasize about my passengers rubbing
one out as I drive so I can help them
what I had an uber driver who didn't
speak English I gave him directions and
he started yelling at me when I left I
realized I wasn't in a Hooper last night
my date was sweet and sent an uber to
pick me up my OB driver was my husband
I'm separated from I'm a lyft driver a
girl I dropped off left her purse in my
car I went to return it and she leaned
through the window and gave me tongue
whoa I'm an uber driver
I just gave a plastered couple a ride
and earned $20 they had sex in the
backseat of my car and left a stain it
wasn't worth it my tinder date from last
night was my uber driver for my tinder
date tonight awkward